في الاثناء افادت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
باطلاق 18 صاروخا من جنوب لبنان باتجاه
راس الناقوره تم اعتراض ثمانيه منها واشار
مراسلنا الى انفجار صواريخ اعتراضيه
اسرائيليه في اجواء بلده الناقوره جنوب
لبنان وكان المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
دانييل هكاري اعلن مقتل جندي واصابه تسعه
اخ تسعه اخرين نتيجه اطلاق صاروخ مضاد
للدروع قرب قريه اقرث المهجره شمالي
اسرائيل يوم امس ورجح الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
عناصر من حزب الله نصبوا كمينا للجنود بعد
استهدافهم الموقع مرتين بصواريخ مضاده
للدروع وقال ان عده قذائف اطلقت من جنوب
لبنان باتجاه مزارع شبع المحتله دون
اصابات بالمقابل اعلن الجيش مهاجمته
اهدافا لحزب
الله
معنا من الجليل الاعلى مراسله الجزيره
فاطمه خميسي ومعنا من ابل السقي جنوب
لبنان مراسل الجزيره ايهاب العقدي اهلا
بكما وابدا معك فاطمه وجديد التطورات على
الحدود بعد اطلاق حزب الله صواريخ من جنوب
لبنان وكذلك القصف الاسرائيلي باتجاه
لبنان نعم يعني قبل نحو ساعه تقريبا دوت
صفارات الان ار في راس الناقوره في الجليل
الغربي وتم رصد دفعه صاروخيه كبيره اطلقت
من الاراضي اللبنانيه باتجاه ذلك الموقع
في راس النقور نتحدث عن 18 صاروخا فقط
ثمانيه صواريخ تم اعتراضها من قبل
الدفاعات الجويه الاسرائيليه وبالتالي حتى
هذه اللحظه لم يتم الاعلان عن وجود اي
اصابات او اي اضرار ولربما تكون هذه
الصواريخ المتبقيه قد سقطت في اماكن
مفتوحه ولكن لم يتم الحديث عن وجود اي
تفاصيل اخرى المنطقه باكملها تحولت الى
منطقه عسكريه مغلقه يمنع الدخول اليها
ويمنع ايضا وصول الطواقم الصحفيه الى ذلك
الموقع بالتوازي مع ذلك المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه قامت بالرد على مصادر اطلاق
هذه الصواريخ في بلده الناقوره اللبنانيه
عبر سلاح المدفعيه مطلع هذا اليوم كان
ايضا هنالك رصد لعشر قذائف اطلقت من
الاراضي اللبنانيه باتجاه مواقع اسرائيليه
في مزارع شبعه المحتله المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه ايضا هاجمت وقامت باطلا عده
قذائف باتجاه اطراف البلدات الحدوديه
اللبنانيه هذا فيما يتعلق بسير التطورات
على المستوى الميداني اللافت ايضا ان
الاستياء الاسرائيلي في الجبهه الشماليه
لازال على حاله والان بات يتصدر حتى يصل
الاداره الامريكيه قبل قليل قام سكان
الشمال الاسرائيلي من من يسكنون البلدات
الحدوديه الاسرائيليه والذين تم اخلاهم من
منازلهم والذي يقدر عددهم باكثر من 70 الف
اسرائيلي بالتوجه مباش باشره عبر ابراق
رساله الى الاداره الامريكيه يطلبون
الاداره الامريكيه من ان تغير سياستها
الدبلوماسيه بما يتعلق مع الجبهه الشماليه
وبما يتعلق مع سياستها في الشرق الاوسط
يقولون ان بسبب هذه السياسه وبسبب عدم
دعمهم لعمليه اسرائيليه موسعه ضد لبنان
وضد حزب الله هم اصبحوا بمثابه لاجئين في
في بلادهم لذلك هنا نرى ان على المستوى
الاسرائيلي هنالك استياء شعبي جدا كبير
هنالك ايضا ضغوطات يتم ممارستها على
الحكومه الاسرائيليه يقولون ان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه تتقاعس في شن هجوم كبير عسكري
يمس بقدرات حزب الله العسكريه واليوم بتنا
عبر رصد العمليات التي يشنها حزب الله نرى
ان هنالك تصعيد في وتيره العمليات لا سما
وان البارحه تم نصب كمين لعناصر الجيش
الاسرائيلي وتم استهدافهم مما ادى الى
اصابه تسعه جنود بجروح متفاوته وايضا تم
الاعلان عن مقتل جندي اسرائيلي الذي اصيب
بجراح جراء استهداف بصاروخ مضاد للدروع
الاسبوع الماضي وبالتالي هذا يرفع ايضا
حصيله القتلى في صفوف الجيش الاسرائيلي
الى 11 جنديا وايضا الى من صفوف الجيش
وايضا الى اربعه قتلى مدنيين اسرائيليين